you you've been living in Ireland I did
I lived in Ireland for seven months last
year yeah last summer I lived in dalke
oh lovely which they say is the Amalfi
Coast of Ireland and I can tell you from
being in the Amalfi Coast that is not
correct
it's the amalthy ghost of Ireland
that's correct yeah should have gone
over to hosts
and actually lots of artists could
actually because Edward you're a big fan
of Ireland oh my God we used to love
Island I had a group of friends in the
90s and we would literally go partying
in Ireland every every two weeks we're
into Dublin front Lounge backgrounds the
Jaws
[Music]
oh yeah
I had a friend called Miss panty Miss
panties
yes I used to work with panty Bliss in
uh elephant castle Yeah it was a waiter
there and I was busboy yeah yeah he
hasn't changed a bit by the way
I only remember the kitchen the kitchen
that's right yeah yeah and re-roves
around the corner of the kitchen the
Terence Hotel yeah
no yeah it was a mistake to have this
many Irish people on the show
[Applause]
[Music]